I need to defeat them on the spot.
I need to survive no matter what!
Well, I'm not sure
if this is accurate, but…
It's a…
It's a phone!
Hey, hold on there!
Let me borrow it!
Let me borrow your phone!
What? Sure.
Is that you, Yuri?
Rika.
It's Rika!
That's right. I haven't eaten anything.
Do they even have food here?
What's that?
It's packed with lots of stuff.
Could these be provisions?
I even found this.
A white cardboard box.
It's somewhere on the rooftop.
You'll find a Mouthless Mask in there.
It might be pointless to put
the mask on right now in this situation.
Even so, I…
I want to save Mayuko!
There it is!
I see the code!
Please, Mouthless Mask!
Give me power!
Give me the power
to survive in this world!
The power to protect Mayuko and everyone!
KEEP ONE'S SELF NEAT
Is it due to the crack in my mask?
I've regained a modicum of control
over my own thoughts,
yet not enough to defy the Commands.
Goodness.
Does a cracked mask mean that
I'll be attacked by other Masks?
This could be troubling.
I get to reunite with Rika!
And one more thing.
I've got a little favor to ask.
That Mayuko girl…
Mayuko Nise, right?
The one who became your ally.
Shoot her to death, right now.
Sure, okay…
What?
Yuri, you can't let your guard down
thinking you've got an ally now.
In this world,
you need to kill before you get killed.
What you need to do right now
is to kill Mayuko Nise
and wait until I rescue you.
Yuri, all I want is for you to be okay.
It's chilly.
Hey, Rika, if you're going to
continue talking like this,
I'll kill you instead.
Are you saying
you're prioritizing her over my rescue?
That's right.
All right.
We'll hold off on me coming to rescue you.
Let me get in on
your helicopter usurpation plan too.
Oh, now I get it.
According to my intel,
the helicopter arrives at a depot
somewhere every day.
So instead of meeting up,
we should wait in different places
to seize our chance.
He said that horrible idea
to test my determination.
We'll gather allies and weapons
for tomorrow's helicopter and--
You know what, Rika?
What?
You really have a twisted personality.